[Musica]
fantastico vedersi definiti changemakers
è una parola che per decenni abbiamo
usato con reverenza con timore
reverenziale invece mi piace contribuire
a scardinare questa idea in realtà non è
necessario essere premi nobel non è
necessario essere geni o eroi ciascuno
nel suo piccolo o grande può essere
attivato reattore di cambiamento
ci sono tantissimi esempi penso ai
bambini di strada di haiti che hanno
innovato il sistema della sicurezza
stradale ha una sola ricercatrice
tedesca che è riuscita a mettere in
connessione
gli scienziati rifugiati con quelli
locali una ragazzina nord americana che
ha scritto centinaia di lettere ed è
riuscita a costringere il provveditorato
a cambiare i manuali scolastici che
avevano immagini stereotipate delle
donne quindi ora il il ponte che vorrei
contribuire a costruire
stamane il cambiamento che voglio
affrontare riguarda il il terzo settore
il cosiddetto non profit e in
particolare il modo in cui guardiamo
alle organizzazioni del terzo settore il
modo in cui ci rapportiamo ad essere
quando diciamo terzo settore
abbiamo ci riferiamo a una galassia di
associazioni organizzazioni non
governative e organizzazioni di
volontariato imprese sociali cooperative
fondazioni ed enti filantropici 340 mila
enti 820 mila dipendenti 6 milioni e
mezzo di volontari nel nostro paese un
settore che è cresciuto del 60 per cento
negli ultimi 15 anni e oggi conta l'otto
per cento nel comparto produttivo
italiano
ma perché ci interessa il terzo settore
non sono non sono solo i numeri il terzo
settore ci interessa
perché si occupa delle cause che ci
stanno a cuore perché si occupa
dell'umanità del pianeta delle persone
più fragili che amiamo il terzo settore
ci interessa perché fa la differenza per
un mondo migliore perché ha la capacità
di immaginare l'impossibile è di riunire
centinaia migliaia milioni di persone
per una causa vedere le persone con
disabilità mentale come persone
innanzi a prima di tutto guardare ai
bambini con disabilità come bambini
soprattutto prendersi cura delle persone
anziane come persone risorsa o di una
bambina malata come una bambina e non
soltanto come una paziente offrire un
approdo sicuro alle donne vittime di
violenza domestica combattere il
razzismo promuovere l'inter culturalità
tra nuovi cittadini e far capire alla
gente che viviamo in un mondo
interconnesso in cui per esempio
l'estinzione delle tartarughe marine a
policoro e un danno enorme per la
biodiversità di tutto il pianeta
ok la crisi climatica di questi giorni
oggi riguarda qualcuno e non altri
ma in realtà ci riguarda tutti le
organizzazioni del terzo settore non si
limitano a tappare i buchi o le voragini
di un sistema di welfare italiano
obsoleto e inefficiente le
organizzazioni del terzo settore non si
limitano ad attività di supplenza le
organizzazioni del terzo settore possono
di questi chiari di luna
direi devono fare la differenza a
cambiare il mondo trasformare la società
innescare processi che riescano a dare
valore non soltanto per il risultato
finale
e che producono ma durante tutto il
percorso magari lungo accidentato che
mettono in atto
ora questa mattina
vorrei contribuire a sfatare due miti
due falsi miti che due muri ideologici
due falsi miti che hanno in realtà
impedito al terzo settore del nostro
paese di cambiare il mondo
tenendolo sotto schiaffo e lasciandolo
in una situazione di sudditanza e di
dipendenza due falsi miti la riduzione
all'osso dei costi di struttura e il
lavorare solo per cicli di progetto sul
primo
il mantra imperante e le organizzazioni
del terzo settore devono costare poco
tutti i finanziamenti vanno destinati ai
progetti
quindi niente fondi niente soldi per la
comunicazione il fund raising
il management lo sviluppo tecnologico e
digitale lo sviluppo gestionale e un
percorso un processo di isomorfismo che
crea un ciclo della fame i donatori non
vogliono finanziare costi di struttura
le organizzazioni del terzo settore si
adeguano e riducono i costi di struttura
i donatori finanziano sempre meno costi
di struttura
questo dogma nel nostro paese e
incontrastato in tutte le procedure le
prassi dei donatori pubblici e privati
ma anche nell'opinione pubblica
anche noi anche noi quando doniamo
quando ti amo il nostro 5 per mille
quando doniamo per una causa quando
sottoscriviamo una petizione una
campagna quando partecipiamo ad un crowd
funding vogliamo finanziare progetti e
non organizzazioni quindi
questa ideologia ha creato dei
progettifici nelle organizzazioni del
terzo settore con organizzazioni
strutture staff troppo spesso inadeguati
tanti giovani del nostro paese
forse le menti ei cuori migliori
vogliono cambiare il mondo vogliono
essere protagonisti di questo
cambiamento si avvicinano al terzo
settore e poi scoprono si rendono conto
che non solo tutta la vita ogni anno
guadagnerebbero il 35 40 per cento in
meno degli altri settore profit ma anche
che lavorerebbero in organizzazioni
sottosviluppate sotto sotto capacità te
a cui si richiede di fare sempre di più
con meno
e allora la domanda per me è perché in
qualunque settore le imprese
diciamo in generale le organizzazioni
che investono nelle persone che
investono nelle capacità che investono
nello sviluppo finanziario nella
comunicazione sono quelle che hanno più
probabilità di successo
e invece nel terzo settore questo cambia
e anche l'imprenditore che nella sua
attività di impresa conosce benissimo il
valore dell'investimento
sull'organizzazione nella sua attività
filantropica vuole finanziare solo
progetti in italia le radici profonde di
questa di questa ideologia sono
affondano in in vari terreni la cultura
del volontariato cattolico l'inconscio
di un paese in cui per centinaia di anni
i servizi sociali sono stati svolti
gratuitamente dalla chiesa e in
particolare da donne religiose e laiche
non pagate una
serie di dichiarazioni di facciata
nella lotta alla cultura della furberia
quindi evitare che i furbi o gli pseudo
furbi possono riuscire a finanziare gli
amici degli amici
in generale la mancanza di fiducia
sociale nel nostro paese e da parte dei
donatori la mancanza di la paura di
assumersi responsabilità di scelta
le organizzazioni del terzo settore
hanno un bisogno vitale di supporto al
cuore di finanziamenti flessibili di
finanziamenti sulle organizzazioni di
finanziamenti sulle missioni perché le
organizzazioni possono essere forti
capaci innovative creative finanziamenti
per missioni e non solo su progetti e
quindi andiamo al secondo punto
i progetti possono essere bellissimi ma
rimangono chiusi in loro stessi chiusi
in una cassa centripeta attorcigliata su
se stessa che incapace di trasformare la
società che incapaci di costruire una
trasformazione è sistemica e di
provocare un cambiamento sociale
lavorare per progetti vuol dire lavorare
per obiettivi specifici reinventare una
squadra con dei consulenti con dei
collaboratori con del personale di
progetto ogni volta vuol dire lavorare
su tempi orizzonti di tempo estremamente
brevi sei mesi un anno due anni tempi
che sono ridicoli per riuscire ad avere
un investimento vero sul cambiamento
sociale
se io penso ad amazon per i primi sei
anni è stata in perdita e ha avuto un
capitale paziente quel capitale paziente
quel capitale paziente flessibile che
nel terzo settore
non c'è per affrontare i grandi temi la
diseguaglianza crescente il razzismo il
cambiamento climatico l'impoverimento
culturale i grandi temi di oggi tutti
intersezionale
bisogna investire su missioni su
missioni interdisciplinari su missioni e
dare flessibilità alle organizzazioni di
investire sulla comunicazione di
investire sul fundraising di investire
sul digitale sull'organizzazione stessa
le organizzazioni alle persone ci sono
bisogna veramente cambiare le modalità
da parte dei donatori le modalità di
erogare di finanziare di sostenere
superare la logica dell'erogatore che dà
al beneficiario il beneficiario che
riceve e costruire invece una
partnership di lungo periodo finanziare
non per sei mesi un anno due anni ma
veramente per 57 anni almeno è riuscire
a finanziare su missioni da parte delle
organizzazioni del terzo settore anche è
necessario smettere di adattarsi e
quindi riuscire veramente a dire quali
sono gli investimenti necessari e i
costi evitare liso mor fismo che a cruz
le ha costrette a fare esiste perché
produco progetti e produco progetti per
esistere all'inseguimento delle modalità
dei bandi
esistono già ci sono tanti iniziative
pilota pochissime purtroppo nel nostro
paese per il momento di nuove modalità
di finanziamento diverse dai bandi che
sono invece ancora la modalità
assolutamente dominante nel nostro paese
da parte mia penso che sia oggi abbiamo
veramente l'opportunità per costruire un
nuovo ponte un nuovo ponte tra donatori
investitori finanziatori organizzazioni
del terzo settore che in realtà però un
ponte che ci riguarda tutti in cui
ciascuno di noi e tutti insieme possiamo
veramente fare la differenza
giovani che si avvicinano per la prima
volta al terzo
settore meno giovani che invece vogliono
restituire capacità e competenze
tutti insieme possiamo fare la
differenza perché si tratta veramente di
un cambiamento culturale e quindi il
ponte che va costruito e un cambiamento
innanzitutto di pensiero di cultura
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]